We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine.
That number is two one nine two.
David p.
Here's an idea from a viewer sort of suggesting
a trade between abortion law and gun safety
law.
Take.
My name is Robert.
I'm looking for, um, to leave a message.
I want to know how you felt about possibly
doing a national compromise regarding prolife
and the Second Amendment, uh, perhaps putting
limits on abortion in exchange for limits
on guns.
Um, I know the current situation shows that,
you know, babies are the right, is moving
more for just getting rid of the abortion,
but would it be worthwhile to pursue a compromise
on that?
So it's, uh, limits on abortion in exchange
for limits on, um, does thank you.
I don't think so.
I still listen, I've been calling out this
issue for 10 years that exists when our members
of Congress make laws where they put together
a bill that is about a funding, uh, health
insurance.
And then other members of Congress come in
and they say, okay, I'll support it if in
the bill for funding health insurance, you
also sponsor some pet project here that has
nothing to do with health insurance or some
pet project there or this pork or that.
I'm against it.
I think this is one of the, the, the most,
uh, sort of destructive elements of how we
do lawmaking in the United States.
And particularly when you're talking about
such major issues, I mean a woman's right
to get a medical procedure that she and her
doctor determined is the right one is a really
important thing in a country that claims to
be about liberty and freedom and self determination.
Uh, keeping people safe with reasonable gun
safety regulations is an extraordinarily important
thing given that we have hundreds of millions
of guns, if I recall correctly, that's the
right number of guns in the, in the United
States.
So I would be very hesitant to, even though
I am sometimes pragmatic to a fault, I would
be very hesitant to take that approach and
say we would give up some abortion restrictions
that we find to be completely immoral if they
would give us some gun safety regulations.
I think we've got to keep the, keep these
things separate and actually negotiate them
and fight them on the merits individually
and not get lulled into the game.
That is part of the problem.
This is the game we're trying to change and
I get the appeal of saying, well, we're trying
to change the game.
Maybe here's an example of how we can use
the game to our advantage.
I get it.
Uh, but these issues are too important to
do that.
Uh, and I would be against it.
On the bonus show today, we will talk about
New York City Mayor Bill De Blasio announcing
his presidential campaign.
We will talk about the United States birth
rate in a record slump, a 32 year low last
year, and we'll talk about what the impact
will be.
Bigger picture, it might not be all bad.
We'll also tell you about how one of the Republican
Bathroom Bill Authors from these Trans Bathroom
Bill, uh, fiascos, uh, has actually secured
the Republican nomination in North Carolina's
Redo of that totally fraudulent fiasco that
took place.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show, two ways to get access, become a member.
Hi David pakman.com/membership become a patron
at patrion.com/david Pakman show.
I'll speak to you that